Hi, this is Jason.
How can I help you this afternoon?
You tell me!
I'm looking at my new statement...
...and I see that you people have charged me again...
...for the same fees I've been calling about for months now.
I'm sick and tired of being told that it's handled when pretty clearly, it's not.
I'm so sorry to hear that.
Let me take a look at your account and find out what's going on.
Can you remind me when this started?
Fine!
The first fee showed up three months ago.
If you can't fix this, I'm going to close the account.
I completely understand your frustration.
Let me see what I can do to help get this taken care of for you right now.
I'm glad I was able to get that issue taken care of.
It may take up to 24 hours for your account to show the changes...
...but you shouldn't see any more of these fees in the future.
Thanks for working with me to figure it out.
I want to apologize again for the inconvenience.
Thanks, Jason, I appreciate your help.